they have this big misconception that we
as Muslims find it so offensive so this
Christmas tree behind me so so offensive
to me when I see I start crying and I'm
like oh no why is it that women are
being punished why that's why I do why
was your commentary why - why can't
women always about it man why does it
seem
now why would it's in mention to you
guys brothers and sisters is that on
that day a man came and invited me to a
Christmas Carol yes they said that you
know why don't you come and join us
yeah okay and I'm gonna play that little
video of the man himself
actually let's watch that first let's go
let's watch that first inshallah yeah
and let's see what exactly happened one
other was that speaker's corner had an
interesting little dialogue with a
gentleman that we're all probably
familiar with gentleman called Ali Dawa
and a leader I seems to want to come and
speak at our events so I went up to our
I said Ali what about coming to the cow
service I would like to cordially invite
you to come and sing praises to God you
are a religious man let's let's worship
God together of course Ali turned me
down very very politely very polite
young man that he is and he said to me
sir would you pray with me
I said I'll pray with anyone I can I
pray I pray to my god and you would pray
to your God
so now that went back was a forward zone
and it was it was good humoured it was
light-hearted and I walked away from
meeting a leader and I thought what a
terrible tragedy a leader was life is a
nice polite intelligent young man who is
zealous and passionate about what he
believes totally committed to his belief
system now you can see from this
gentleman his take on the matter how we
came and invited me and I kind of
rejected the reason I rejected is
because I'd it's against my religion to
be involved now because we believe that
shift is the biggest sin so I'm not
gonna go there and glorify Jesus which
when I believe Jesus is a prophet and we
worship the one who created Jesus so
this man came and I flatly refused and
only reason I refuse to do so is because
if I said them I said to him would you
come and pray with us they said yes I
will but I would praise Jesus I said
exactly so the thing is I have no
problem with you celebrating your
Christmas what if it maybe singing
Christmas carols or whatever it may be
to be honest if you go to the Book of
Jeremiah chapter chapter 10 Jeremiah 10
verse one to five
it clearly tells there you know this is
a the description where it says do not
cut trees from the forest and bring them
to your houses and decorate them yeah so
the Bible is against the Christmas tree
concept not as Muslims and even if you
look at some of the scholars who have
trans exegesis of this verse they say
that this is not referring to Christmas
trees but even still they agree that
Christmas and the Christmas tree has got
nothing to do with Jesus or his birth so
the Bible is more against you than we
are and this is one big misconception
that a lot of people have so they have
this big misconception that we as
Muslims find it so offensive so this
Christmas tree behind me it's so so
offensive to me when I see I start
crying and I'm like oh no this is
misconception that when you guys like
non-muslims have pork we feel that
deeply sudden and even at one instance
when the far-right came to the park we
had a lady called Amy he was waving
hammer toes like were vampires when the
vampires is a garlic would just all in
all stop it we're going to pass out so
this misconception out there of whatever
it may be like Muslims have a problem
with Easter that's why I test cause to
stop selling ear eggs this is a big big
misconception a big misconception she's
not tell you guys why because if we look
in history for example when the Prophet
peace be upon him that for some the
Treaty of Niger oh yeah the Christians
used to live there and I listened to one
of the treaties the lives of the people
of Niger on Christians and the
surrounding areas their religion their
land their property their cattle and
those of them who were present or absent
their messengers their places of worship
are under the protection of who Allah
and the guardians of his prophet their
present States shall Nate neither be
interfered with nor their rights meddled
with nor their idols deformed not be no
Bishop should be removed from his office
the intentions being that no change in
whatever state everyone is shall be made
etc etc etc now the question that needs
to be asked is this when the Muslims
were ruling over the Christians and the
Jews when they had power they did not do
this so when they were in power
they did not come and say you're not
celebrating Christmas you cannot do this
your churches whatever you had can stay
with you they lived under peace not like
when the Crusaders came and slaughtered
men woman and children
latias happy days in that in the book of
Samuel chapter 15 verse 2 to 3 where it
talks about God ordering to go to the
Amalekites and store to men women
children babies donkeys you know so the
issue here is this when Muslims were in
power they did not impose their ideas
and stop the Christians on the Jews from
practicing their faith what makes you
guys actually believe and think that
when we're living in your lands we're
living in your lands and we abide by the
law of the land as Muslims we should so
what makes you think that when were in
power we did not do it but when were not
in power we're gonna try to impose this
this is a big lie it's a fallacious
reason it's it's actually prophetic I'm
being really straight with and I've told
them that when they came to me telling
me come on get involved with the
Christmas spirit whatever it may be I
said look I have no problem zero problem
with you celebrating Christmas Easter
Valentine's Day whatever it may be I
don't me personally I will not be
involved I will tell my fellow Muslims
to also not get involved but you in your
country you can celebrate what on earth
you like it's got nothing to do with me
so I just wanted to make this video for
you guys near Christmas is nearly
Christmas share this with your friends
and family especially non-muslims I want
you guys to understand that we are not
here to take over the Sharia whatever
we're not here and you guys may know
that with me specifically and our team
will be confront the only certain
Muslims who are brainwashed and Jim
Choudhary's followers we have confronted
these people why because they give us a
bad name now just a few things I want to
finish off with historians here these
are non Muslim testimonies people who
lived under the Islamic rule not the
fake Isis combat
mystery and John the penque in 690
expressed fascinating sentiments
regarding the reign of moi we're yeah
Roger Lohan the peace throughout the
world was such that we have never heard
either from our fathers or from our
grandparents or or seen that they had
ever been like that yes
Burnett the white a pilgrim monk
Egypt and Palestine in the reign of
halluf alberta's 866 - 869 this is what
he stated the Christians and the pagans
the Muslims ie the Christian and the
Muslims and the pagans that's what he
classified the Muslims as takers they
have this kind of peace between them
that if I was to go on a journey and on
the way my camel or donkey which bore my
poor luggage was studied I think it
meant that you know it couldn't operate
anymore and I was and I was too abundant
all my goods without any guardian and go
to the city for another pack of animal
when I came back I would find all my
property uninjured and in peace
this is non-muslim testimonies who lived
under the Sharia yes the Sharia that you
are so scared about yet they lived and
these are their testimonies
so Providence is in a nutshell very
simple and to our dear friends who are
watching this I've said this before I'm
an Orthodox Muslim I've made this very
clear when I confronted talking Roman
something I shouldn't call my religion
my religion comes first I'm a Muslim
first its town comes first for me so now
I'm telling me very straight up to your
face the very following I me Muslims we
don't have no problem with your
Christmas celebrate your Christmas as
much as you like yeah this I'm I'm in
Turkey right now yeah we got invited by
somehow via guests when in Turkey this
is a Muslim country you can say I've
seen more Christmas trees here then I've
seen in England yeah everywhere so the
issue is if it's such a big thing
because it's what become a cultural
traditional thing we have atheist and
even have some Muslims who celebrate
this which they shouldn't but you
celebrating Christmas eaten pork having
bacon sausage whatever it may be
yeah you can do as you please in your
lands we're not here to take over it's
just a little misconception that was
there and I wanted to highlight a few
issues and I want to kind of thank the
gentleman who said some kind words
towards myself and he said you know I'm
a gentleman you know I'll kind of I
thought I can be quite a gentleman as
well yeah so I just want you guys to
know that Tommy Robinson and his knights
want a civil war between us it's not
gonna happen we're not gonna allow it to
happen
Wow Tommy Robinson is subpoena Scotty in
his confit poem of his a million pounds
who's getting a hundred grand a year
making
and people like Anjem Choudary and Isis
who are brainwashing our youngsters when
we're fighting each other and killing
each other they're going to be having
confidence in their hosts watching in
their houses watching TV when Evan
allowed that's happened thank you for
watching this video hope you guys have
understood this misconception hope is
cleared for you guys to next time for me
Salaam alaikum wa rahmatullah America
true